truly I am like living my dream ten
times over and I have to remind myself
of that all the time I think I would
tell a younger me like yeah the thing
that you think is so different about you
will be the thing that allows you to
support yourself in the future and and
people will celebrate that
you did it [ __ ]
for a long time I didn't feel
comfortable calling myself a comedian I
think I was still like really you know
thinking of these like rigid guidelines
like I had to do stand up every night
and I had to have been in something and
and then I kind of finally got more and
more comfortable with the title but yeah
I think it was people you know tagging
themselves in my videos and and
requesting more videos from me and and
during that time I felt more and more
comfortable being myself and and kind of
having that creative output so yeah it
was like a little combo and then finally
I think you know if you tell yourself
enough you can be like I guess I am a
comedian if all of these videos are
comedic sketches like that does track
but yeah it was definitely like a long
process for me
as far as turning it into a business
I think you know it can be really scary
and you don't want people to think you
know you're a sellout or or that they're
being like used in a way or that you're
just always selling something people
come to my page to watch a comedic
sketch so if I work with a brand if they
want to control the whole thing or or
make it more of a commercial it's just
not going to be funny and it's not going
to do well so I think a great example is
my the work I've done with Mac Mac just
kind of championed me from the start and
was like we want you to make whatever
you want and so I did and I think that
you know the videos I've made for them
have done just as well as videos that
aren't branded so I think that's a great
example of just when a collab is right
it works I really always make what I
want to make I don't try to Pander too
much I think I did earlier in my career
I wanted to please everyone and I think
my most successful videos have been when
I just wanted to make something that was
making me laugh so I think actually
anyone who does that will set themselves
apart
I've been working on a TV show for a
long time that I hope people get to see
very soon I'm in Chelsea Peretti's new
movie first time female director I think
feeling like you can be in those spaces
and that you've earned it is kind of
hard I think you know there is kind of
this slight snobbery around social media
and social media people or people who
came up on the Internet which I think is
unfounded because a lot of these people
are making their videos all themselves
they're you know they didn't have an
access point into the entertainment
industry I think the iron gates of
Hollywood kind of have come down a
little bit and that's exciting because
there are new voices that are entering
the space more diverse voices more
voices that need to be heard and I think
that's the pro of social media being in
the Kardashians was this kind of like
full circle moment that felt like kind
of a communal win for all the people
that had followed me since I was doing
Kim videos with like a two dollar
Contour stick and a t-shirt as my wig
now I have better wigs and better makeup
but I think that that was just kind of
like this really fun moment and felt
like being able to do that has opened
the door for you know other
collaborations with people maybe I've
done impressions of or kind of opening
the door for people to
um reach out and maybe collaborate it is
funny though I don't you know I don't
have Courtney's number or anything but
soon come I hope of court
I need the digits girl
oh
for you know four years I was just like
editing videos in a coffee shop in
Williamsburg so I think being able to
perform live is a privilege and I feel
so lucky to get to do that and and get
to see the people who have responded to
my work and the fact that they would
come to a show is definitely an honor
and it's just like so much fun to
actually see the dolls laughing and I
think my favorite thing is when someone
would come to a live show and they would
have on like a wig or like a bright
lipstick or a fun outfit and they'd be
like I dressed up for you there's
something about that that makes me
really happy that maybe people would
feel comfortable being more themselves I
try not to judge myself when I'm making
things and I hope that I've inspired
people to do that too you know you can
do something for you and you can also
like be all of yourself I think queer
people and women are always told to be
smaller whereas straight men you know if
they do like anything we're like yes if
they do anything extra we go crazy we
love it but if a queer person or a woman
does it it we're like okay we get it
settle down like whatever you're being
too much and I hope that I've you know
made people feel like they can be too
much because I think that's exciting and
I think they deserve it and you owe it
to yourself to be fully who you are so
yeah I hope I've inspired people to do
that I hope that's my legacy
[Music]
thank you
[Music]